the Joe Rogan experience there's gonna
be a comedy club that says [ __ ] let's
get opening somebody's going do it
somebody gonna do it you just can't make
people sign waivers say the the club's
not responsible if you get sick you
think is that irresponsible to do is
that irresponsible to do I don't know
is it look tell people to get tested
tell them to get tested when it's
available when testing is readily
available and treatments are readily
available
I think only then are we gonna relax
yeah I said it yep it's the question
it's like what do you how do you tell
people that you don't have it like if
you go to a bar are they gonna are you
gonna submit to having an app that's
problem that there may be some type I
heard in Wuhan or whatever they have
some type of system where it is an app
where I guess you register and you could
scan and see I know there has to be in
development - I was just talking to
somebody about it I don't know exactly
what it is but I think that that
technology exists
do you follow Willie D from the ghetto
boys yeah go to his Instagram and he's
got a post where there's a company
that's sticking a microchip in these
people's arms they hired a [ __ ]
professional tattooist and piercer a
professional piercer what could that has
to come like for you to get what the
[ __ ] imagine if your company tells you
to I know I know you don't want to bring
keys you know finally bringing keys
everywhere just can give you a little
microchip I'm gonna make sure you're
showing up at work on time enough to
punch in anymore you're all set you're
gonna go for it they're going forward in
this video laughing and joking around
about it that is real right we can get
hosts do we get hosts cuz it was it's a
new story I don't know about it on his
page but I know I know exactly we're
talking about someone real good this
company embeds microchips in its
employees and they love it and I see
employees at times we got RFID chips in
their hands those are probably people
that know that anything they probably
so that anything that the government
wants to find out about you they could
find it out whenever they want look at
this when Patrick McMullan wants a diet
dr. pepper while he's at work he pays
for it with a wave of his hand Oh we'll
definitely don't carry credit cards
anymore that's too hard to do there's
this dude it's let him put a microchip
in you and pay it with a wave of your
hand
I think LaGuardia one of the airports in
New York has got the experimental thing
going where they have in one of the
terminals a place where you can go shop
you just swipe your credit card when you
walk in and you just leave with whatever
you got and they charge you like like
those Amazon stores it's the same
technology I guess Amazon's licensing it
out well that makes sense it's still a
credit card though like it's not a
champion this is or you don't waive your
card I think you just have your phone
with you kind of and it's just like
knows that you have as long as you can
leave it at home this you can't leave at
home this is what's so crazy about this
how hard is it you lazy [ __ ] you can't
pull your [ __ ] credit card out you
you're willing to let them put a
microchip in there so you can get a diet
dr. pepper Louis my move
you can loan somebody money would adapt
at his office
he's one of dozens of employees who've
been doing likewise for a year now
that's very funny imagine that's how you
give you to the man yeah you can't touch
now because Coronas who you know I
couldn't baby bra social distancing
McMullen is the president of three
square market a technology company that
provides self-service mini markets to
hospitals hotels and company break rooms
last August he became one of roughly
fifty employees at its headquarters in
River Falls Wisconsin would volunteer to
have a chip injected into their hand
[ __ ] yikes what I saw was a dude was
getting it in his forearm I was it must
be a different company so this is what's
scary is this gonna be the new norm like
what if you get fired by these people
when you get hired by Amazon you have to
put in one of their chips you have to
take out your old chip do they sell the
chip to the company uh this would be
when you leave give me my chip back oh
my god they cut you open but that
doesn't that does not surprise me in the
least it doesn't surprise me but
alarms me it alarms you that people are
so interested in having someone put a
chip in their body but we can company
that tells you you have to do it their
company tells you have to do that [ __ ]
that company but I know it but those are
people that feel that they need they
need to feel the need of being a part of
new technology I wanted if that's the
hot [ __ ] [ __ ] gonna have it
this was 2014 says microchips will be
implanted into healthy people sooner
than you think
it's gonna happen yeah it's gonna happen
I mean they call this it's gonna happen
for people like I say look think about
it Joe somebody with Alzheimer's yeah
you know I'm saying they're gonna find a
smart reason if somebody is um abducted
you know I'm saying it's like it's weird
to think about it but didn't if you
really think about it it's it's gonna be
weird but it's still not there's gonna
be plenty of reasons we're gonna say
tell me where your chip is and people
don't want to tell us that cut your hand
off this article I don't like did right
here the talks about this guy getting at
a year later Ghassan infected his own
implant with a computer virus one that
could pass on to other computer systems
if the building's networks were
programmed to read his chip as Gasol
breezed around the workplace spreading
the virus and corrupting computer
systems certain areas of the building
became inaccessible to his colleagues
Jesus Christ that's that's how didn't
that's how war is gonna be for to us
yeah [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ] if
you can fight it words like this who can
hack this [ __ ] that's where the words
that it's not gonna be the physical [ __ ]
it's gonna be like you got one
[ __ ] in the room
yeah that could crash some [ __ ] like
that you know what that [ __ ] do to
everybody
[Applause]